yo welcome to this video galit got a lot
it's no name right yeah I've got to I've
got some games against them 16 out of
eight that's a nice score so what do we
get yeah i'm going to play the Queen's
Indian for a change to something
something different I add that liner yes
I don't know this is a very sharp line
if I go Bishop e7 and c5 and I simply
don't know it so I'm kind of chickening
out a little bit and switch to something
else yeah this is a funny line with the
bishops dancing around but it is it is
completely okay for black alright fairly
typical Queens Indian position type D
697 this kind of thing Bishop g5 that's
not a very ambitious move does you just
want does it just want to take it on
okay
okay yeah he's not as I mentioned hey
it's not really doing that much mostly
trading stuff I'm very very solid but
it's not not that I can do can do much
maybe five is a moose yeah I can play
five but it will mostly trade trade
stuff
okay okay so what if I if I take here on
f three years is a move I'll any form
let's let's try that at least it gives
some imbalance Jim don't don't know if
this is really doing me anything doing
me any good or just uh yeah this is the
kind of pseudo active move that at the
end only leads to trouble and sometimes
difficult the same
gen well plug is completely okay but I
still cannot do very much who is
allowing III that's kind of surprising
okay so let's play it
didn't expect that to happen that that
he allows this push okay probably f4 has
to be played no no it's not playing a
form that's surprising so if I trade
everything what is he doing then check
rooty 6i gobookee six Jack Jim dunno if
I really yeah okay let's take it check
approved e6 probably rook e6 and again
he will check me in probably the rook
trade is just one sided of this is nice
now I can really play for win not well
not with huge chances of success but
there are some okay that the interesting
question is should i play a five or not
and when I should be g5 actually right
Jihan is good preventing King f4 and
then king over 25 the reason why black
is somewhat better here is the pawn
structure of course he's got all those
pawns on light squares so I'm a bit more
comfortable because of that and now 94
check is becoming an issue so he's
reacting to that um so
hmm ok maybe night over to the six not
completely sure what the best way is ok
now 94 and 95 is an idea ok is
preventing that night at five now is
probably probably a little bit it's a
little bit too little oh ok so let's
reshuffle regroup
hmm
I wanted to go to see six but now now
this is this is coming let's see how do
i use this not so easy I want the knight
on f6 to play age five maybe okay yeah
this is what I wanted not sure if this
is Charlie helping me or not time
warning might see six not doing much a
night back to Knight to f6 and then h5
is probably the better way to do it the
adults trades are actually not that
welcome 94 f 2 this is an IDM I still
don't get age five and maybe I have to
okay
so I'm getting getting the F to pawn and
the h3 pawn I was what i was going to
say
we are looking at the c-4 point so that
the king is tied to this pawn and now I
can use my hiking to support the Jeep on
Jay yeah this is going to go to f1 check
and picking up the points now okay that
was a nice end game which I mean okay
it's hard to say um probably I didn't
play it very precisely but it's a very
very nice position to play around here
where you are absolutely sure that
you're pressing pressing forever and why
it has all the problems with this pawn
structure yeah this is a problem at
these pawns also it might be just a draw
with optimal play but it is um it is
pretty pretty awful to play in a
practical game I was shuffling a little
bit the only the real problem came lay
down so we got this here so I think up
to here it's okay but this is this is
probably not a great idea okay so the
computer still says this is the draw why
I maybe my night is strapped gem if I if
I go if I take him neither stripped ok
let's of that's it's definitely a point
yeah then then this is probably still a
draw computer is on 000 which is
probably the true evaluation
yeah if I can never take the H pawn then
this is a huge issue but he went here
and no I'm just winning yeah I could
have taken on a three witnesses I think
the simplest solution there's really no
way to prevent what what happened can
just step by step process that can what
can really not prevent in any any any
case it was a bit I mean okay
objectively probably no big issue but it
is really in this in this position um
why it shouldn't trade rooks here it's
it's much simpler to a channel can give
this check or not and then then just
play this kind of position with King f2
bishop is bishop is pretty okay it's
probably easy i took two to let those
pieces yeah to have them stay on the
board and yeah not simplify and well as
mentioned objectively it's a draw but
it's it's a bit it's a bit one-sided and
especially in an inner blitz game I
don't know I key i would have kept the
rugs on that maybe it's not objectively
a mistake okay hope you like that thanks
for watching